[Music]
good morning party people we are coming
to you live for an episode of honest
trailer commentaries can you hear the
echo echo star that's Dave Moreau we're
alive and we're working out the kinks
new old studio same old problems yeah
we're talking about the Oscars on his
trailer today I imagine yes yes we did
last week so hopefully it's live right
now for your enjoyment or maybe in an
hour no one knows live now we're live
right now to the world watch that come
back watch this here our insight into
the eight Best Picture nominees and a
little simply it seems at the end I
think per usual yeah a couple of things
so gentlemen the Oscars wards with the
stars shine brightly on the streets of
Los Angeles this is Oscars dad what's
the Oscars take on this year's Oscars
it's been a mess matter of fact we
should say one of the reasons that we
went live with this today this morning
instead of pre-taping it on Friday oh
right
was that we had to hurriedly rewrite
sections of this trailer because they
reversed yet again one of the decisions
so then we had to like change the
beginning change the end of it and this
is crazy I wish you YouTube still let
you do annotation so we could just be
like sorry we wrote this before they can
change their mind a seventh time we're
not actually going to rewrite it but we
won't do it because they just rehired
Kevin Hart yeah what a hot mess
it's like they're on a dare to see how
many people they can piss off before the
show yeah they just keep racking up
points it's it's weird that you know
just uh just just make a nice award show
that's like oh yeah they keep being like
let's razzle dazzle no that's I was
reading a story yesterday with the head
producer of the show and she was like
you know they it's like what with all
the changes you're gonna make three-hour
the three-hour time she's like no but
we're trying to figure out how to make
the show something besides award award
commercial award commercial award award
like you just want to not do an award
show there yeah if you don't want to
just like hand out a bunch of awards and
go to commercial then I don't know what
kind of show you're attempting to
produce because that's literally what
the Oscars is yes so stupid cuz like you
know the Grammys and the Tonys have the
benefit of like you can do that art live
yeah I didn't have musical performances
you can have people do what they're
being awarded for which the Oscars like
you're not gonna have them all act and
then you just have like Bradley Cooper
and Lady gaga like reenact yeah or like
every year all of the Best Actor and
Best Actress and supporting nominees all
have to do to like at least a scene from
12 Angry Men like ever yeah
just everyone does a scene from a famous
play where you make like the big
timeline and premiere and they're just
quietly like all the nominees editing at
one time to see who cuts together they
cut battle maybe they have a movie by
the end of it like they make a short
film
oh yeah I like that the hairstyles are
styling their hair yeah we solved it
movie magic people live at the Oscars
you um I guess that's all we'll say
about the show because most of this
trailer is about the feelings themselves
a lot of movies to tell let's do a lot
of movies let's start it and then we'll
discuss each one as they proceed and I'd
lost my headphones you know I know it's
I can hear through your I know it's
gonna help to microphone
it's time once again for the oscars who
after pissing everyone off by suggesting
a new popular film category pissing
everyone off by hiring indoor firing
Kevin Hart and pissing everyone off by
cutting that uncut important award from
the show rewrite will now be pissing
everyone off by awarding Best Picture to
one of the following eight nominees now
pause Rick just something about the
field this year like I think that people
will be mad no matter what yes always
that's usually the case but I think it's
especially the case there's usually some
people mad at the winner but this is I
think this is a weird feel the Best
Picture nominees were like no one's
really behind one yeah specific one but
a lot of people seem to be against
several of them yeah everyone already
turned against the star is born' idea
there was like the huge groundswell of
support for it and then I think people
just got over it like really quick yeah
everyone hates Bohemian Rhapsody yeah
for people who like it yeah no one feels
anything about vice really yeah yeah it
was like green book is like loved and
hating Roma is not seen by most but
divisive amongst those who did see it
yeah like Panthers just weirdly divisive
for some weird reason it has to do with
the quality of the movie I guess yeah
and is that all of them black Klansmen
black Klansmen I guess that would be
like people wouldn't be mad I think I
usually the one about the KKK is the
most people what the hell is the
favorite like yeah I've never heard of
it
yeah so yeah I think it's a lose lose
lose lose lose lose lose lose injury
yeah at the very least I'm gonna be like
you know spike garnet like it's a long
time coming for spike that's fine and
then they'll move on yeah anyway let's
keep going yeah your brother from a
director comes the combination of wigs T
and Mike Myers in jokes you didn't know
Freddie Mercury deserved well that's the
kind of song T
can crank up the volume in the
accountant bank the red suit in this
moment it is one great Rami Malek
performance from being the non parody
version of wall car the Dewey Cox story
I don't need any I just wanted to know
whether they were proud of you what are
your parents think about your protest
song being human is conditioned and
positive so anesthesia okay Freddie
Mercury's got to think about his whole
life before he gets on stage Freddie
Queen of raw so pause it's very timely
Mary Queen of Scots gonna love it
pretty clean trucks credit to Kevin our
editor because we in our haste and just
laziness really just wrote in the script
Oh JT Kevin how are we fixed thank you
are we thanked no well not in my head I
just turn into a Kevin our editor we in
the script just wrote just wrote
Bohemian Rhapsody slash walk hard clips
yeah not knowing what we wanted really
at all just confident that that joke was
probably in there somewhere and god
bless him oh yeah holding him killed it
step two of that I believe I don't know
what the exact order was but I leave I
believe it was something like Kevin
saying coming to Dan first maybe and
being like what walk hardship clip
should I use and and being like I
haven't seen it in a while that's Joe
should I use you know I haven't seen in
a long time that's a Spencer or Dan
question I haven't seen one it's been a
few years yeah
watch it
sorry yeah sorry Kevin yeah to be fair
we were it was eight movies at once good
job you crushed it and luckily the joke
was there yeah
but human Rhapsody I think is a it's
kind of well to me it's like kind of
Forrest Gump syndrome where it's people
hate it because of the Oscar prestige
around it like I'm perplexed by that
yeah but I'd like I don't know why this
is nominated for Best Picture
but as far as musical rock jukebox
biopics go it's like Oh Freddie Mercury
you're wrong I'm Alex doing a really
good Freddie Mercury and I love Queen
music yeah but the movie itself is not
it's just not that good never nominated
for Best Picture
but best Freddie Mercury impression yes
it's a good one yes a great it's a great
performance inside a very standard media
yes movie and yeah I didn't hate it I
feel like people I guess the thing that
people hate the most is that it's not
not accurate historically well I know I
know
yeah ever and it's not like it's not the
greatest showmen where they made him do
a different person it's like it's yeah
they squiffed some dates our man on the
moon is a great Andy Kaufman biopic he
didn't have cancer when he did the
Carnegie Hall show but it made for a
better movie like that just kind of like
a heroic tortured or yeah yeah I mean
history is written by its own but I
would never go into this thinking oh
this is the real history especially
knowing the backstory of like the band
being so protective right and everything
yeah it's a ludicrous to think that
that's actually how yeah there's a great
performance I thought a very mediocre
movie with great music and that lasts
the liveit thing was great like that
there was a well really well done
sequence I don't know who directed it
but it was really well edited yeah
nobody knows a maybes that directs most
of his cool thing is like Nightcrawler
and made in the White House he didn't do
it yeah so yeah so interesting much
maligned for for fair reasons but I
think wouldn't be getting nearly as much
if it wasn't a Best Picture yeah yeah
yeah it's just like that fun biopic that
came out it is ridiculous that it's
nominated for best bit yes yes I will
openly acknowledge not a great film all
right keep going in a world where the
Dark Knight Logan
The Avengers Deadpool and the Wonder
Woman were overlooked for Best Picture
and fans have spent years dropping that
no comic book movies ever get nominated
for the highest award one film will
finally get the nod leading rabid fans
everywhere to say I guess it was good
but was it that good there is no
pleasing you is there Black Panthers
third act look like a PlayStation
cutscene and did it really pick up
enough nominations to win and I
personally like inventing or better in
further money so yeah that's our that's
at this point the the backlash to the
backlash against Black Panther is it's a
really good movie and if any comic book
film deserved it this year I think it
was black panther more so than infinity
or again great film
but I picked writer verse in there
before they're personally fair fair
enough yeah um yeah I would have put
both of them in over bohemian rhapsody'
long list yeah and I really do think it
actually might win which is insane it's
got as good as any of them yeah have you
seen the Guild Awards this shit's crazy
like the Writers Guild Awards or this
week and it's like this is the one award
show that will finally tell us who's a
front-runner and the Oscars because the
Green Book and vice and all these other
movies are up for it and it went to
eighth grade
nope nobody knows they're all split the
Academy Awards are absolute chaos yeah
so I do think that like the big
crowd-pleasing super popular hit with
like the social conscience aspect that
that you would want from a Best Picture
movie like it's checking a lot of boxes
I don't know it's as likely to win as I
would be as I said I'd be surprised but
not shocked
yeah I'll get one Best Picture but yeah
it's I just found it's very ironic that
for years now 10 years starting with
really The Dark Knight it's every time
there's a great comic movie so why
didn't it get pollinated for Best
Picture and then one does and it's like
well not that one it's like well hang on
like even if you don't like Black
Panther and I wouldn't have nominated it
for Best Picture either but I have I
don't begrudge it being nominated and I
understand why it was nominated and it's
a really good movie even if you don't
like Black Panther you would think if
you're a fan of comic book movies at the
very least you would acknowledge that
there is a great step forward toward
recognizing the genre so maybe in the
future if there's one that you like
better the precedent has been set now
that it could potentially be included
yeah yeah but nerd culture is gonna eat
itself so it's not gonna think like
currently like literally snakes tail is
i sat next to a was at lunch yesterday
sitting next to two guys in a very small
restaurant that were loudly discussing
every Star Wars talking point for the
last 15 years is it on the curb enough
already
it's my god Wow feel like Shatner in
that and that the Star Trek sketch he's
like come on this is supposed to be a
lark yeah good lord
so yeah be be happy for how far we've
come ya know who'da thunk
when the MCU got going that they're
being black panther will be nominated
for Best Picture who'd a thunk
who'd have thunk it not us let's do a
favorite y'all go slothy from your ghost
length
from the direction of the lobster comes
the other Queen biopic nominated for
Best Picture this year that's also about
a difficult charismatic figurehead and
the people who jockey for power around
them and feature scenes of its eccentric
demanding main character surrounded by
cute furry animals I'm not gonna lie if
this movie into with Queen and
performing at Live Aid did have my vote
Bohemian Rhapsody yeah pause pass so
this movie lon was telling me it's
actually a lot more accurate than
Bohemian Rhapsody like there really was
this jockeying for power Nikolas Holt's
character was real and was trying to sue
for peace and trying to gain the
influence of the Queen's you know
handlers and everything but the rabbits
really everything but the rabbits and
the you know explicit sexual
relationship it was like rumored at the
time it was like hmm this is probably
going on but no one there's no pictures
but the otherwise this is
[Laughter]
I will because of the lobster clip in
there Kevin again shout out to Kevin
pointed out that john c reilly pops up a
lot in the streets because he popped up
at the Dewey Cox thing he popped up in
that clip from the lobster he pops up
again and we talk about Vice fights for
stepbrothers john c reilly is this year
anyway so but it's weird he's literally
independently popped up three different
times this is the other one that I don't
mind if it winds like this weird bizarre
movie and the way he moves the camera is
really interesting and I don't know it's
it's a just a really odd out there movie
is it just me or does it feel like the
law in think should have happened this
year yes like happening would have been
the perfect capper to this and not the
one two years ago for them to screw up
the Best Picture it absolutely that
would have been just yep it now feels
like based on what we know now about the
Oscars it feels like the la-la-land was
them dark universe in the Oscars where
they were setting up we don't know how
to do this franchise like right at the
end of their Oscars it's impossible that
the dark that the la-la-land moon like
thing was the hinge point for the crazy
alternate universe that we're all living
in now like it's the grey sports Almanac
of this time where there's a line where
they just said moon light and everything
just cording the plan but we're in the
time line clearly values on his phone
and they said lala land and everything
went crazy and and and like a like a the
world's craziest butterfly effect
everything is just butter flats what
else has big wings knocked over there's
now like like 20-year storms hitting Los
Angeles what's the movie code where it's
out of orbit next to Jupiter now
wondering why
now now review to come Dan I hope so
maybe I was thinking about it just to
just let people know what the hell's
going on it's crazy and I want to I
don't want to move to China but I want
to see more movies from China and I
don't think I want to move there quite
yet yeah all right let's keep God from
the mind about you Jeff Daniels chronic
diarrhea comes a film based on the
personal stories of discussion they were
completely refuted by the living
relatives of this guy dignity always
prevails as the civil rights era south
is handled with as much subtlety as
you'd expect from the guy who made
shallow hell oh there she is there's
rosemary where right there she behind
the Rhino the drink
I guess Jason Alexander has a habit of
playing like the horrible horrible
friend in rum cubs
pretty woman this isn't pretty woman I'm
just realizing like I mean someone's
gotta do it
someone's gonna make that like third act
like horrific act that them that the guy
is gonna be like whoa wait stop yes hole
I'm not like you anymore
yeah I've spent an hour and a half
changing yeah so that we can't play
pick-up basketball anymore my entire
life
the last shot is always ham on the court
with the basketball yeah or he's been
like he falls in love with like her
weird best friend who's right she's so
weird to remember things about Shallow
Hal yeah I feel never again like stuck
on you
well the Farrelly Brothers sir wants and
done one of their one of the reins but
Gwyneth is too good to be in Marvel
movies okay fine he's only done a time
oh yeah all right you know she thought
that this movie was gonna be like
life-affirming for women sorry for that
dead guy said well that's some things
the Farrelly Brothers like they try like
they seem to have like
we're gonna make this message like like
the Chinese Knoxville won but the
Special Olympics yeah like our message
at the end is going to be good after two
hours of maybes people that how stupid
they're that one's fascinating because
johnny Knoxville legit is like a massive
support of the Special Olympics donates
money participates every year and he had
been up to that point and so the a does
he like process of making that movie of
him being like this is great guys this
is great guys this is great guys this is
great guys just having no idea like it's
weird yeah before we starting up again
there is I don't know if you can ever
find it but there's a hilarious old SNL
sketch with Jeff Daniels or he's on a
talk show
yes and it's like inside the Actor's
Studio and every time they queue up a
clip from his work it's just him on the
pole with diary every time let's look at
this clip from The Fabulous Baker boys
or whatever I don't know I mean there's
a comedy news blooper where they they
kick to that instead of the clip like
somebody keeps on yeah really oh yeah
that's gonna be with them forever yeah
all right thank you and the Rhino
featuring show-stopping turns from a
Hershel ollie
as Don Shurley and Viggo Mortensen as
one of the cartoon Italian chefs you
steal the pizza box I make my boss with
the powerful message that racism and
stay with me on this is bad whoa oh oh
yeah green but yeah I feel like we
summed it up pretty much in that this is
a good social movie made by boomers who
are just like I just want to say racism
is bad and feel good about it that's
really all I kind of want to do and it's
fine it's made for boomers made by
boomers that's kind of how I saw that
movie
two great performances that probably
deserved it slightly yeah I mean this it
feels like Best Picture 1998 maybe 92
yeah yeah something like that yeah I
guess yeah you know when you
the thing that doesn't bug me about them
because like I thought it was fine and
the performances are great but it's like
if you really follow it well okay
a couple things aren't right in that
it's completely made up largely fiction
I think that aside is that like Marshall
Ali's character like dontre Lee never
never gets to know how racist have ego
is like throwing out the glasses that a
black person touched before he meets my
Hershel ollie
and like there's never that reckoning
like there's never that knowledge
between the two of them like he's just
kind of like his sort of standoffish but
like he's a nice driver it's a great
movie
personally part it's a great movie and
the Viggo Mortenson thing is Best
Picture nominee in 1987 right put in the
work actually - and how great is Viggo's
journey that he learned v meeting like
truly one of the most incredible
african-american or otherwise people of
all history that like he's like the
cultural sauce I didn't hate it actually
liked it it had its flawed I get that
it's flawed
I still think at its core it's about
people finding common ground and putting
aside their differences and I don't
think that's necessarily such a bad
thing but I know but if it's a great
message I'm not gonna go after him
because they were trying to make
something positive and this crazy
sure la-la-land world that were in but
it doesn't bother you that they took
somebody's real life and twisted that to
a separate issue
I mean I think there's the movie and
then there's the making of the movie and
there's two different I think there's a
couple different there's it's a
multi-faceted conversation which means
it's boring you know
[Laughter]
you've seen 25th hour you didn't okay
you've seen Malcolm X no that's great in
that you should talk about mostest I you
see the right thing
stop remarking if it looks like a minute
okay let's start over
you've heard of Spike Lee yes the guy at
the Knicks games now strapped in for a
terrifying portrait of white supremacy
in the 70s that's just as relevant today
which earned Spike Lee his first Best
Director nomination and really puts a
damper on reruns of That 70's Show
god bless white America someone should
really make this David Duke guy watch
Green Book Juwanna Klan
I let Kevin break the tie and he picked
correctly it's not just a pun like oh
this sounds like this it Juwanna Mann is
also about somebody going undercover to
infiltrate the WNBA
so there's parallels there words man
it's a layered punch yeah you know it's
not my favorite Spike Lee movie but I'm
glad he's getting getting his do yeah I
thought that you know it the way it toed
the line between like comedy and
suspense kind of deflated the suspense
of it for me like I felt like I should
have been more on the edge of my seat in
a movie about this guy going undercover
with the KKK but a lot of the time they
were just kind of like busting out jokes
and stuff like that which apparently is
more true to the real story like if you
read about the the real guys retelling
it's like these guys were morons like
they were never really close to
uncovering yeah that's sketchy going on
like they were idiots so obviously they
had to like build in some some tension
and some like suspicions on their part
but it never quite like gripped me as
far as I as much as I thought the
premise should have that said a fine
film and I'm glad he's getting on it I
loved it until I had at some people some
people's favorite part of the movie my
least favorite part of movie was the end
when they tied it directly into today
because that felt like you know there it
was a it was a very good metaphor or at
least sort of
and in for what's happening today and
then I felt like the last five minutes
the movie Spike Lee just took a 2x4 out
just like slap the audience is like
Spike Lee saying for two hours which I
got it from the rest of them but I
understand why other people feel
differently because it's certainly very
evocative and visceral and it does end
it with a bit of a gut punch but apart
from that I love the rest of that movie
again it's why it's better to give the
audience you know two plus two and they
have them go for instead of saying two
plus two is four yeah and you're right
that's not a it's not a it's not the
first time Spike Lee's done that he's
that kind of filmmaker he's very
provocative filmmaker and he wants to
evoke the maximum amount of emotion out
of an audience yeah I felt those have
been unnecessary for that film but I
understand why people feel differently I
think it's I think it works for an
audience today because when you watch
people communicate and stuff online like
nothing's on a team and like everything
can be twisted for whatever you want
like someone can be like the sky is blue
and people on the Left can use that and
then people on the right can can use it
for the same thing and so I think for
spike Lee it's like I have to have a
very specific because even with you know
like the Charlottesville stuff they use
like people on the right will and all
right and even you know people that
support the Klan and blah blah blah will
somehow weirdly twist like yes
the Liberals who were angry at the Klan
there are bad and so I think with an
audience with an audience like that I
think you know Spike Lee's got to kind
of go like two plus two is four it's not
negative five it's not like lala land
weird reality for it's just for like you
kind of got to be direct man I feel like
if you're gonna deny math exists then
telling them the two plus two is four it
doesn't really help we all know where
Spike Lee stands KKK yeah I think he
stands on the side of Green Book all
right let's do vice from Adam McKay
who's a walk for an Oscar nomination
secular physical transformation from
Christian Bale who's been skinny fat and
bad in a dick change biopic that's one
part drama one part comedy and 18 parts
makeup with a powerful message that
unchecked Authority abusive power and
shady tactics and stay with me on this
far bad dick not much to say I mean the
I actually had the same issue with this
film as you did about black Klansmen
which was when he broke the fourth wall
and addressed the camera at the end of a
vice and he was like all right II think
I'm a jerk like I was Oh he want me on
that wall you need me on that wall we're
like the met and I guess my issue is in
broader terms is like I didn't know what
message you were supposed to take away
from this except that like this happened
or this guy existed and but I was seeing
it as more of like kind of like a farce
or like a comedy of errors where this
guy just kind of bumbled his way into
this position of immense power and he
didn't really have an ideology he was
just like doing whatever it took to
serve himself yeah and then at the end
he was like I am the true American
patriot hero that you don't that you
deserve like that wasn't the movie I
just watched play yeah it was a mixed
bag yeah there was a lot of different
things going on in that film yeah which
I liked a lot of them and some of them
was like all right yeah like Big Short
was chaotic and crazy but like also
weirdly focused at the same time with
like what it was trying to get across
you and right yeah and then the like it
was a definite love/hate moment of like
the early roll credits
like so much of who he is I imagine
comes from being like the global oiled
CEO guy leo that seems like it was
pretty much a pivotal part in his life
but what do I know Adam yeah I think was
a good film if you don't know much about
that era in politics like a nice cliff
no it's a really fun entertaining
CliffsNotes about about the Bush years
but but as someone who
I don't know live through it was at
least marginally aware of who he was and
what he was doing I was like yes yes I
know okay
I remember yeah yeah I wasn't there but
I didn't know the early life stuff then
yeah I mean there was such a [ __ ]
sorry anyway sorry everyone gets one
alright let's do a SARS barn first time
director Bradley Cooper comes a film
comes along once in a week you'll
literally like one since every
generation since 1937 featuring New York
born immensely talented world-famous pop
star Lady gaga
in the role of a lifetime as California
born immensely talented world famous pop
star Ally and featuring that one Lady
Gaga duet you can't get out of your head
no matter how hard you try obviously we
have a lot more to say about that movie
yes maybe in a fortnight's
trailer or or what have you so maybe we
shouldn't dive too deep into it here
yeah I don't wanna say I don't want to
be repetitious but I can just say that
good lord that our Kelly video is
uncomfortable
yes she's managed to scrub it mostly
from the internet but it's like he's
basically operating on her as a patient
and like getting her all types of horny
because met so yeah our Kelly should be
in jail
and apparently when all this came out
and she pulled it sales of that song
went up so we're all going to hell
naturally yeah that's how that reality
pulled right envelope
let's do Roma let's dig in the robot
works the company who wants to earn its
big-boy pants comes a film that got
Academy voters to wonder what it would
be like if their housekeepers were
actual people in this intimate sweeping
emotional portrait of 1970s Mexico
he pulled straight from its directors
brain and stunningly realized through
dazzling acting and cinematography that
you skipped because it's so much easier
just to rewatch the office again bears
beets Battlestar Galactica tiding put
the elites every
all right buzz roma roma beautiful film
a little too quiet and slow for some but
to me haunting and gorgeous and I'm sure
would have been even more important had
I known any about that time period I had
to read up on it and then look back
around the the basically revolutions
going on in Mexico at the time that were
kind of literally happening in the
background of that movie yeah I don't
know like guys I just thought was I
really liked it I know a lot of other
people didn't
I found it haunting and gorgeous and
quiet and slow yeah you can pause any
point of it print that and frame it and
put it on your wall and it would be a
beautiful piece of art God knows how to
shoot a movie yeah and that's what I
said when I finished watching it hmm but
one that I think will will hold up even
better down the line is there's like
more like it's interesting when you
realize that I'm a real mediocre brain
when it comes to film when you see
someone like like Guillermo del Toro was
tweeting about this movie and was just
pointing out like so much that I didn't
notice about it and like the metaphors
of water and like the ways using
different imagery and like all this
stuff and I was like whoa like there's
certain films where you just know that
like there's so much more going on under
the surface and I can only tell that
there is more going on I just don't know
what it is right and this is one of
those movies impaired - Guillermo del
Toro we're all mediocre he comes I had
social media essay like that and I'm
like I'm not Shum on users orange
sometimes he uses like the orange to
represent the good and the blue for the
brown I'd love to see Carroll del Toro
do like that kind of thing on YouTube
but he does it with like the cheap arrow
thumbnails with things circles that's
how you get four million people to watch
a game el Toro like detailed breakdown
of a film as he makes a YouTube video
with like the waves with a red circle
around it and a big arrow yes thumbnail
like 69 things you didn't notice about
Romo exactly like shot from just above
in Philip defranco's living room
for some Christmas see the big like Mike
and he's sitting clearly like at his
computer with like a wall of DVDs that's
how we do it yeah thinks I don't know
man let's get him let's get him on how
do you do it I don't know all right
that's it for Roman wrap it up story
special guest star following Oscars
knobs it can be hard to be snubbed
second right doesn't have odors you're
talking memory was the biggest nub this
year oh well that's mighty nice of you
to say neighbor but I'm just worried
about these other fine films getting
their due but I would have been pleased
as punch if they kept the awards for
best makeup and hairstyling on TV or
best editing or Best Cinematography oh
that one's important send them and table
Murphy can you say that
cinematography very good you gotta be
changed their mind miss Rogers those
awards are back in the show oh they
changed their mind about my film to know
well isn't that a kick in the patoot but
they could still give an award for best
stunts Tom Cruise put his life at risk
for your entertainment isn't that
special lots of women made lovely films
this year
Deborah rainbowfish urban Ramsey come to
mind I love your anniversary I admired
you to protect children but maybe not
with a hammer but you know oh and of
course Toni Collette I don't want to be
a potty mouth
but that's messed up excuse my language
no problem mr. Rogers it's a beautiful
day on the internet when you're around
the Oscars 2019 leg I hope be today yeah
I think you have to be the worst Oscar
since the Lala line debacle
or since crash one or since Franco and
Heather way hosted or since the Oscars
were televised you know what I didn't
realize until watching this back for
like notes and stuff is the guy who
screwed it up is in that shot of him
holding up the envelope oh wow JC can
you go back to the wall and shot so wait
wait wait wait
[Laughter]
you know how'd that happen he's beating
a path out of that shot possibly can
yeah well there you go on the other side
that's a great loss huh love it if it
keeps giving yeah we I can't recall the
name but that's a but big thanks to our
last-minute mr. Rogers impersonator who
I believe does the voice of mr. Rogers
I'm feeling like I'm not credited now we
will make sure to add it to the credits
of the trailer he's in the credits okay
I I feel so bad it was very last minute
he came through very last minute first
thankfully and was great and did that
and I I so props because otherwise I
think they did sound like John talking
to himself it did yeah because he he
does a mr. Rogers and I think if it
wasn't right next to his own voice solid
but yeah it does sound like he's like
gone crazy okay well that's not the
deleted scenes but let's uh let's see
what else again not story best us a
hosts best makeup and hairstyling yeah
best editing but who cares about editing
am i right yeah what are you waiting for
cut to something else already oh not
that fine okay we need editing boys take
in your god damn right 20:19 there's a
lot of pent-up Kevin I just had to watch
this for no reason yeah clearly we need
editing we're nothing without editors
yeah except for this show we're doing it
live for nothing without you JT yeah I
feel like we have to wrap it up because
we have to do another show in a few
minutes yeah so let's uh let's just say
thank you for watching to this point and
we'll be back next Tuesday for one of
the films you just saw I think you can
guess which one
watch this video and and it sounds like
the place is falling all right well say
goodbye real quick
[Music]